kourtney kardashian is clapping back at
trolls claiming she had lots of plastic
surgery i'm just like living life and
whatever happens happens it all started
when a kardashian fan account posted a
throwback photo of courtney kim and
chloe
in the comments one fan accuses court of
having a ton of plastic surgery even
going as far as listing specific
procedures
but turns out it was not the day to mess
with the eldest kardashian sister if the
situation is right no better compliment
than a too good to be real kind of
compliment butt shot in brazilian butt
lift um thanks and you were just getting
started this isn't the first time the 42
year old reality star responded to
uncalled for opinions
recently court posted a snapshot of
herself emerging from a swimming pool
and when one commenter wrote quote not
to be that girl but is that a pregnant
belly court quickly replied with quote
are we really gonna do this every time i
post a photo
gee goodbye
back in august the keeping up star
posted pics in a bra top and skirt
writing quote say hi to my closet and
again a commenter asked if she was
pregnant the comment said quote is there
a baby in there someone else asked
simply prego and court defended herself
like a queen writing back quote i'm a
woman with a body i love it yeah it
seems like courtney has more important
things to worry about like walking down
the aisle
[Applause]
beautiful amazing the pooch founder is
set to marry her fiance blink 182
drummer travis barker after getting
engaged in october
i love you
[Music]
you